I've got some weird news for all of you
turns out that my brother is a
semi-professional video blogger and he
actually is incapable of making a
youtube video right now this is not
actually a new phenomenon I've been
helping John take little baby steps into
using computers for more than just word
processing web surfing since this
project began and John is in the middle
from switching over from iMovie to Final
Cut Express which is something lighted
recently and is a big pain in the ass
but it's taking him a really long time
to figure it out which is a little
disappointing because we all thought we
were gonna want to meet a fat sandwich
today yes that is correct my
nerdfighting friend the punishment has
been chosen and it is to dissolve
protein powder strawberry flavored I'm
not kidding into Crisco melt it and then
chunk it up into a fat sandwich mmm 100%
the same as a Charles juniors six pound
Porter bubbie mushroom whatever the
thingy because John eats his hamburgers
his way and that is the way in which you
actually see how gross it is he has done
it and he has filmed it and I have
watched some of it John's initial
reports were and I quote for the first
two bites it was delicious
and then I puked which frankly is how we
all should respond to Charles jr.
burgers they taste delicious but really
they should make you wanna puke I also
have another piece of news to share with
you uh I got a new toy today in fact I'm
using it right now I actually have a
wide-angle lens now watch this oh oh
yeah white angle what wow what wow so
yeah I got a wide-angle lens which means
now I can make my face all crazy just
pretend like I got a humongous nose it's
great and of course I got some plans for
this puppy but nothing that I've got
prepared right at the moment so on you
just consider this a teaser a teaser for
John's fat sandwich eatin self and yest
he got the strawberry flavored protein I
don't know why he's so into the self
flagellation so yeah
this particular technical difficulty has
been extremely frustrating we can't get
the audio in the video to sync up and
we're pretty sure it's a YouTube problem
because they do just fine on John's
computer and it's completely unwatchable
because the awning of the video have
nothing to do with each other so it has
been kind of a bad day for John not just
because he had to eat a fat sandwich so
I think to say thank you to him once he
gets that bad sandwich video up I would
appreciate everybody commenting on it
and most especially favoriting it
because you know that John eating gross
things is your favorite it's my favorite
you know see your favorite too and to
finish this all off please enjoy this
video
of me playing Dance Dance Revolution on
a high school musical three dance pad
because that was the cheapest one I
could
[Music]